essayer de faire ça calmement je suis
désolé mais je dois saisir votre regard
à son intéressant déjà perdu tôt ou tard
il devant les bois ça lui a pratiquement
toute sa vie la peau c'est comme en
chine
tu vas bosser comme un fou entre
l'entrepôt et le wind et même si ça
rapporte un peu ton père tu es direct a
passé bien vendu août a pas vendu assez
cher mais si tu veux tu peux récupérer
l'argent de la prochaine récolte qu'est
ce que bono tu as dit exactement que tu
cherchais un an dro planqué ton stock
c'est juste un seul coup est un titre la
solution pour d autres raisons dans la
maison à la mauricie at espace bern
utilisent internet l'a prôné par miyem
tuque les courgettes la cité normande ou
tard il a pas besoin de votre fric il a
besoin que tu sois l'ars mais plutôt un
jour je croyais être au top au cas où la
com
et vas-y du mocassin
la vraie force tant qu'ils n'ont pas
peur de toi tu peux rien faire
j'ai pu entamer un côté toi
tu crois tu prends ton blé est reparti
fait relâche
je veux bien mentir à ton père et kicker
mais pas toi